hi this is the second uh film in
improving your ones
iido if you're a teacher that is
listening to
the uh ideas I have
and you want to put some energy into
improving the students in general or you
may find that one or two or even one has
that little bit more
to what you know demand from the iido
that they're doing then you could
perhaps uh watch them and push them
while they're doing their
ukis so on the first film I said do 25
uh forward emies nonstop and then
increase them in uh quantities of
10 and backward emies starting with uh
doing 10 and then increased in them as
as you feel I would say increasing them
in fives after that rather
than you the problem is until they work
out what way to turn their head is
convenient and they don't go over like a
square
brick and they can make a nice smooth
roll with of their body uh backwards
then I think it should be done slowly uh
you don't want to demoralize anyone and
if you're a student listening to this
then you don't want to be demoralized
yourself so while you're trying to
become smoother you want to go past the
disorientation stage or dizzy stages and
that's why I'm making this
program for those people who like their
lifestyle just doesn't happen to allow
them to go off to Japan America or
anywhere that's offering a an nesi
long-term program you'd like to improve
um and but you'd like to also live and
work
and your commitments to family or
whatever it may be that doesn't allow
you to just go off as a free person and
take a sabatical for a year or a few
months or years in some cases that has
been in the past
uh you don't often hear now or I don't
of a long-term
uesi because life seems to move on okay
so I started with the ukis because this
will tone up your your buttocks your
body you'll get fitter you'll get better
breathing lung power and um it will give
you an all round uh much better
Fitness what you can do at home if you
hopefully if you have a garden or space
you can find
outside you can do um the Ken or Joe if
you need to know Carters there's plenty
of films out there I've got some on uh
the io.com
uh website that you can follow and try
not to worry about doing the whole
Carter learn just a few moves perhaps
the first five moves of each
Carter we created um a sixc count Carter
Joe Carter but that's taken from the 31
as I've said in other films it's from
number 12 to 18 in the 31 jarta but we
call this a six jarta it's simple to
learn um it gives you a good feeling and
in time you'll build up speed and feel
like you're getting
somewhere the Ken seven K of ID I think
are really good for uh challenging You
So you you're doing new ukis when you
get chance some people actually buy a
few mats and they put them down in one
of the rooms of their house and they do
their ukis this way and if you have the
space and want to buy a few mats then
there's um a company that will sell you
them I think they're called Canon mats
any you can find them in the UK I know
but but most people can find mats
somewhere meter by meter doesn't take a
lot to store just a few just for
yourself to do your ukis
[Music]
on uh any kneeling work that you might
want to do you know shico walking on
your knees anything that uh you need
mats for you can do this in your own
time if you can snatch the odd half an
hour that's really all you need in
a but you could train daily if you're
you know if you have a partner or a
family they may allow you half an hour
to have your own space that's obviously
up to
you so you don't have to do all the
seven caner bures but what I suggest is
you do at least the first um
five um
but the six and seven uh H have the skis
added to them so why I'm saying the
first five is because they're just
really all about subur
Cuts do all seven if you've got time but
like with the buildup of ukmi I suggest
that you do the first to
kerb until you're really
satisfied um try to aim for five of each
now you may think well that's not many
five of each but out of those five
subes I'd like you to aim
for three subur that felt exactly the
same once you can get to three
subur that felt exactly the same out of
the five so you do the five straight off
one 2 3 four five let's say that was the
first
R the brain will tell you how it felt
and and you'll know straight away
whether they're feeling individual or
whether they're feeling uh continuously
the same feeling the same swing rate um
the same grip rate
there's there's so much that your mind
will be giving you feedback and you'll
know and I found by giving this to my
uch that live with me um they find it
very challenging once they get used to
realizing that three is hard to repeat
identically the same with feeling
understanding swing
timing I don't even know after 50 years
of iido whether I could get five Soo is
all feeling the same I haven't done it
for some time so perhaps I'll make my
own test and try that if you can get
three out of five feeling the same
you're doing really
well do this with every
kerb of course you can't do the second
kerur if you've got inside the house if
you got a ceiling because you weren't
about to lift it but the first subury
should be able to be done in most
ceiling Heights but caution is test out
slowly first if you get carried away you
might be hitting the ceiling and causing
me to get in trouble as well as
yourself okay so that's the
system there's a whole seven subes do
them
individually one at a time if you can do
them nightly then
that's what I
recommend it will help with emis
building your mass you will feel more
stable on your posture your your
transfer as your feet move while doing
the seares should become smoother and
you should find that you're you're
gaining a better understanding of
stability and depth as you cut and your
your frame your jigar as we call it your
frame from your hips down through the
legs into the feet should become much
stronger more
stable so that's it for this film uh do
the Carters and this Joe Carters in the
same way try to do piece by
piece again I suggest you do the first
three if you're perhaps a dangr been
doing I it a long time do five but just
because you're downgrade of many years
doesn't mean to say that you're not
getting it wrong and you need
stability so if you're doing the Joe any
Joe Carter or Joe
saures I suggest you just do
three so let's say you do the first sub
Joe subur
chuki
um if you can get three the same as the
can out of the five so you're you're
aiming for five tries of
it and then you're counting what how
many feel the same if none of them feel
the same your aim is to get three that
feel the same exactly the same without
mental
criticism U when you've done that go on
to
kizuki ski and so on ski get so don't be
in a rush thinking I'll try the the mind
will push you and say oh I'll do five
Joe subur is the same as with the Ken
you'll want to push yourself just see if
you're better at some subur than others
but this process I'm trying to give you
while you're in the environment of not
being able to train in a far off land in
a dojo and immersing yourself I'm trying
to give you this the understanding that
I've seen my uh long-term
students develop and most of that means
that you have to do self uh training in
your own time that's how you get better
you don't get better by just thinking
about it you have to spend thinking time
and dedication time to the actual
doing so please don't be in a
rush um your aim is for three out of the
five tries of each suburi Ken or
Joe when you get three that feel the
same I suggest then you go to the next
stage or the next
sauri like I said with the Joe
chuki do five if you once you get
three it might take a month it might
take years it might take only a few days
if you're very lucky I I've not been
that
lucky then when you get three out of the
five that feel the same go to the next
Aur what I will say is you don't just do
the five you might do the
five 20 times in that 30 minutes that
you've dedicated yourself to to to do it
so you you just keep repeating it five
times how many did you feel were the
same
small pause small break just a just you
know even if you close your
eyes breathe out break like you're
breaking the
sequence put your Joe down or hold your
can and start again so a small break in
between each of the five but on the same
subber for 30 minutes a day if you can't
give 30 minutes a day give what you
can if you do it correctly 30 minutes
will be
plenty if you can give yourself an hour
then um you'll be very lucky but you'll
find that you more criticize yourself
too much if you give yourself too long a
period if you condense it into a shorter
period you'll find that that'll be
enough to torment you uh if you didn't
get it right and you wonder why you
didn't get them right so I hope I've
explained it correctly and
clearly you do five of each subur
chosen repeat this daily or as whenever
you can so if you're on the first subur
today you do it five times and then have
a little breather of about half a minute
or a minute then do another five see if
it's the same as as the first five and
then a small breather and do another
five you do this with Ken or Joe you
just need to break the
sequence breathe out Open the Eyes start
again as if it's a complete fresh start
and not just a repetition of swinging in
the Ken I've done five I'll now do
another five you must have a a short
break of 30 seconds to a minute before
going on to the next one breathe calm
yourself don't give yourself too much um
don't belittle yourself or give yourself
too much of a hard time you're looking
for
smoothness and continuation of the same
feeling the same swing the same Pace the
same settling of the
body okay thank you for your time